Travie giant elephants in front of you
interacting with you connecting with you
smelling you listening to you looking at
you telling you to stop telling you to
go away telling you to stay I am fine
with you those interactions powerful to
me elephants are the guardians and
stewards of this wilderness this is
their home the living room of Africa
but SWANA is home to the world's largest
elephant population with almost 140,000
elephants interacting with tourists and
local people every day with no hunting
in Botswana there is no threat if there
is still conflict very few elephants are
killed by poachers each year in Botswana
but every year the number of elephants
poached increases more poachers are
coming for Botswana's ivory and we need
to be ready protect the people and they
will protect the wildlife we stopped to
have lunch at Nellis and crossing not
knowing that the migration was about to
arrive
this elephant died of natural causes the
tire tracks you can see up to the
elephant caucus are from a military
vehicle there to remove the tusks for
storage
the smell is close to the caucus is
unbearable the lion spent the whole day
at the carcass all attempts to feed were
half-hearted full bellies and the
unappetizing smell
towering above us as we set up camp for
the evening is the symbiote bear bed
estimated to be over two thousand years
old
every evening I take a moment to sit
alone quietly and just listen as the
Delta comes to life